the attack happened as prime minister
fumio kashida was about to speak in
support of a candidate in an upcoming
by-election
there was commotion when someone threw
what appeared to be a smoke bomb from
the crowd
a suspect was quickly wrestled to the
ground as koshida was hurried Away by
his security
[Applause]
[Music]
everyone in Japan this attack recalled
last July's assassination of former
prime minister Shinzo Abe again at a
public event as he was campaigning
it was the same when it happened with
former prime minister Abe I was shocked
that something like this happened again
we're seeing similar incidents and given
that this case with kashida follows on
from what happened to Abe I think people
are reassessing the idea of campaign
speeches anyway I'm glad that kashida is
fine
kashida has continued his campaigning
saying the Democratic process must go on
elections the foundation of democracy
and violence like this cannot be
tolerated during elections I also
instructed the National Police agency to
ensure thorough protection of
dignitaries
this attack comes as Japan prepares to
host foreign Ministers of the G7
countries in the mountain resort town of
karawizawa which is now under tight
security in recent times acts of
violence have become extremely rare in
Japanese politics and after ave's
assassination an investigation found
there had been serious flaws in the
security provided for him it's led to
much greater protection for prime
minister kashida its Titan security
that's much more in evidence as he
continues to campaign
Rob McBride Al Jazeera Kuru wizawa Japan